okay so Bobby where we're heading is
100-foot drop off that lip we're right
on the edge of this like Boulder slab of
rock that just curls away and it's one
of these all good ones because you can't
see over the lip we're gonna go across
and try and secure ourselves and then
figure out our way down let's follow
this moss okay all right it's getting
steeper and it's actually a drop off
meaning if I were to take two steps this
way and slide I would fall off the edge
of it it's super slick and scary so
we're gonna need the rope for this if
you got that you got that claw did you
get that we're gonna use these bear
claws they're called talons and dig it
into the moss the moss is only about
that deep though so this is a little bit
sketchy so if you stand on those and
then Marshall hole does well well that
probably would hold its problems your
work yeah I'm more nervous about this
one line Olivia okay let's get this rope
sorted I think this is definitely a
baptism by fire or rather rain and wind
for Bobby these sort of things in
perfect conditions are all really
manageable but everything becomes harder
when you can't feel your fingers and
you're cold or wet through you put your
weight in it Bobby put your weight
because I need your counterbalance on
this that's a key go and keep coming
keep coming keep away from there okay
I'm in the back yeah
good those talons are actually holding
that as a long water slide up
okay here we go well done keep with me
that cookie down keep it calm I said
it's good Bobby
yeah
whoa good job okay and that talent help
looking back hello Stephanie a smart
decision to use a rope on this so from
here we're pushing on what I can't see
is it is Bakke Norway box
[Music]